you know how there are some political
tails that build momentum they sort of
take on a life of their own but they're
just not real like Ronald Reagan's
welfare queen this was the idea of a
woman who was just raking in money from
government welfare programs for all the
kids that she had she was pretty sitting
pretty driving a Cadillac or a Lincoln
or something like that without working
and it was a totally fake story but it
really impacted how people felt about
welfare programs the birther movement
would be another example where even
though there was never any basis for the
movement that claimed that Obama wasn't
born in the United States that he wasn't
really eligible to be President of the
United States even when the birth
certificate was released it didn't
matter right the the committed birther
still didn't believe it because the
narrative was so compelling and these
stories are really effective because of
the sort of imagery and cohesive nature
of the story that's told and that really
sticks with people and it can be hard to
sort of counter that narrative in many
cases and Donald Trump has now been
caught in a similar one of these
examples because of a totally bogus
story that was made up about the death
of a Border Patrol agent and dana
Milbank wrote about this in the
Washington Post really good piece that I
encourage you to check out and starting
back in November Donald Trump started
talking about the death of this Border
Patrol agent
Rogelio Martinez in a way that was
stirring up anti-immigrant sentiment and
meant to increase support for the Mexico
border wall that Trump has been talking
about and Trump talked about losing
another one Martinez who was brutally
beaten and badly hurt and we're going to
have a wall which is interesting because
when you see him say oh Martinez was
beaten and we're going to have a wall it
must be that he was beaten by someone
that would have been kept out of the
United States by that wall because
otherwise why would you put the two
things in the same statement and Trump
even tweeted about it at the time as
well
tweeting back in November Border Patrol
officer killed at southern border
another badly hurt we will seek out and
bring justice to those responsible we
will
and must build the wall and it wasn't
just Trump the Republican Texas governor
Greg Abbott was offering a reward to
quote help solve this murder and to
quote help us catch this killer and it
wasn't just the governor of Texas Texas
senator Ted Cruz declared that the
incident was quote a stark reminder of
the ongoing threat that an unsecure
border poses once again suggesting that
it was a problem that a border wall
would fix and then you had on top of all
this propaganda outlet Fox News
reporting that quote a border patrol
agent was brutally murdered with the
headline Border Patrol agent appeared to
be ambushed by illegal immigrants the
FBI went crazy at the time looking for
the murderer and instead what they found
out was that there's no evidence of any
kind of altercation of any kind of
attack of any kind of scuffle or
violence period there was no attack this
appears to have been an accident and you
could say well David listen at the
beginning it seemed like an attack so
you can't blame Trump and Abbott and
Cruz and Fox News for promoting that it
was an attack not really when you go
back to the original reporting on the
story it turns out that Culberson County
Sheriff
think that the Culberson County Sheriff
who was one of the first people on the
scene said at the beginning don't think
that this is an attack I believe that
either the border agent fell or was
sideswiped by a big rig and Martinez his
partner Steven garland doesn't remember
the event he suffered a head injury
he thought that they might have run into
a culvert so in all likelihood this was
an accidental hit-and-run it's possible
that the driver of the big rig that hit
them might not even have realized that
they hit anybody we know that parking on
the side of the highway is really really
unsafe which is why you're always told
to immediately call for police
assistance if you break down on the side
of a highway particularly when there's
no full shoulder but now it's too late
right the story is out there
narrative is cohesive Border Patrol
agent murdered in the United States we
got to build the wall to keep these
people safe and even though there was
really nothing there no retraction no
apology no corrective tweet from Trump
or Fox News or anybody and we know that
a fraction of the people who see the
original story even see the correction
when there is one so once again totally
bogus story meant to push a political
agenda and we will never we will we will
hear about it because I'm telling you
about it but the people who most need to
hear the correction never will and it's
a really sad state of affairs